they're a big question this morning
about why there was no warning before a
tornado ripped through Tulsa Oklahoma
and ef-2 tornado was on the ground for
six minutes early yesterday morning
without any alert from the National
Weather Service the rare August tornado
tore roofs off homes and knocked down
trees around 30 people who were hurt two
people had severe injuries Omar
Villafranca is in Tulsa Oklahoma where
thousands lost power
Omar good morning good morning 24 hours
after the storm you can see there's
still plenty left to clean up now part
of the storm hit a commercial area where
we're standing and you can see the
damage that 130 mile an hour winds can
do this is what's left of an AT&T store
that roof was peeled over and this kind
of damage as I step over some siding
here you can see it four blocks the
ground was of the tornado was on the
ground for several minutes
interesting note the sirens did not go
off the National Weather Service says
they didn't notice the tornado on the
ground till it was almost in another
city luckily no one was killed
the tornado tore through Tulsa shredding
these restaurants and storefronts in the
Midtown portion of the city at least
eight people were rescued from this TGI
Friday's restaurant after its roof
collapsed other buildings were nearly
reduced to rubble
this stretch of businesses took the
brunt of the damage as the twister
skipped along nearly seven miles we've
got power lines that are down we've got
big trees that are down we have roads
that are closed right now
the powerful system structurally after
1:00 a.m. local time damaged power lines
left more than 15,000 people in the dark
at the height of the storm crews were
out early to get a majority of customers
reconnected by Sunday evening the
twister even uprooted trees bringing
this one crashing down through the roof
of Heather Dick's new home I came down
this street and I saw a good that tree
had fallen I just started crying one big
question people in Tulsa have been
asking why the tornado sirens did not go
off before the tornado came through this
storm was one that developed became the
tornado was doing its damage during this
very short period of time
Roger Jolliffe the director of the Tulsa
Emergency Management Agency says
did not sound the sirens because the
twister had already moved on to a
neighboring city by the time the
National Weather Service issued its
warning I said if it's in Broken Arrow
we will not sound our sirens because the
threat at that time that we got this
information was going in to Broken Arrow
the National Weather Service says they
use two radars to track the storm and
once they saw that the tornado was on
the ground on one radar that's when they
issued the warning when it was going
into the city of Broken Arrow National
Weather Service official told us they're
going to be reviewing those protocols
and the mayor of Tulsa also told us that
once they get some of this damage clean
up they're also going to look at their
protocols charlie omar thanks